on va t'en des sites décerné laissé vide
d'or avec le meilleur invités de l'année
des nominés sont
la catégorie award du meilleur a vite
été pmp de l'année les nommés sont
christian clavier qui a rhabillé les
chroniqueurs pour l'hiver quand on a un
gros gros gros noms on a beaucoup de
choses à faire on n'a pas un temps fou à
lille marie marguerite
montiel de cris
gérard lanvin pour l'ensemble de sa
carrière césar du meilleur acteur pour
moi ne rien dire ouais sait on que prix
d'interprétation pourquoi pas mais en
tout cas ceux qui ont voté pour nous on
les remercie bien sûr on ne va pas dire
je m'en fous non on s'en fout pas
chantal ladesou toujours présente pour
soulever quelques kills tu doit soulever
le qui tient un indice
à lui aussi dans ses comptes
qu'est ce que tu vois chantale
j'aime à dix dernières années 90 il va
devoir prouver qu'elle est le cadeau qui
va gagner
michèle laroque gros son brushing plus
soignée que celui de benhaim michel oui
tu étais déjà belle on a tué sur le
tire-fesses de la beauté
eva longoria pour sa romance avec cyril
[Applaudissements]
alors
enfin à jouer un peu entre clavier
ballon à
l'humour face au charme so lu ment
c'est la classe qu'on poursuive ou
francesca moi je dirais
eva longoria parce que voilà je suis
complètement fan et je la vois le
sourire mais aussi parce que ma femme
est fan et
que la panique ouf
eva longoria et puis vous avez vu la
réaction de cyril ans il est né ce
qu'est ce qu'on se revoie pas eva
longoria dans la dans la longueur
la longueur regardez il va vous êtes
heureux ça va tout va bien vous êtes
content d'être à paris est ce
que je viens à paris j'ai l'impression
d'être chez moi ma rentrée chez moi
on se met des barrières comme ça
pourtant c'est cette seconde là non
messieurs jean petit pied-à-terre à
paris une fois de temps en temps je vais
vous dire un bon français on part si ça
tombe bien moi aussi une fois de temps
en temps le dira la jument anglais you
mais ici
tu es très bon ben ce wpt
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu la chance de l'interviewer dans
le cadre des faits ciel de télévision
monte-carlo faut savoir mais
elle est extrêmement carré vraiment à
l'américaine mais c'est une femme
d'affaires derrière l abbé de trois
assistants qui gérait soit sa garde-robe
est ce que la balle qui
l'a tué en liberté
[Rires]
je suis chopé voilà plus de mes plus
grosses sont matés pmp avec eva longoria
pourquoi il est venu il ya 5 6 ans à peu
près et j'avais ce site est un peu déjà
effet elle faisait des arts martiaux
j'avais fait un faux combat de karaté
avec fait ce monde tomber enfin mon
meilleur jeu d'acteur et ils seront
lequel part elle repart et le
programmateur celui qui programment des
invités vient me voir la pub en dix ans
jean-michel j'ai pas ce qui se passe je
crois que tu l'as fait un effet de ouf
elle m'a demandé mon numéro de téléphone
mais moi j'ai moi j'y croyais que
j'étais à fond dedans quoi donc du coup
une 10ème modem au numéro c'est con ils
vont acheter un téléphone prépayées et
avec un numéro que je ne connaissais pas
masquer xtrac aimons voit un message
signé par eva en disant rendez-vous
demain matin je repars demain matin le
seul chef à bourges et 8 heures départ
du bourget et serra où t'es là où t'es
pas là à toi de décider tu as ta vie est
entre tes mains en gros en anglais ah
ouais mais toute la nuit j'ai réfléchi
j'en ai parlé à tous mes potes j'ai
commencé à faire ma valise quand même
toi d'aller le lendemain matin au
bourget cma baloche commun qui avoue
jusqu'à apprendre que c'était cyril qui
avait fait monter tout ça que les gens
de m'envoyer un fou textos mais j'en ai
marre des matches pas cette approche la
preuve
wen a fait je vous jure que c'est vrai
ma fait la même chose avec patrick bruel
menace avec un téléphone vous allez que
ces foutus de ma gueule à l'été oui je
suis alors et
il a montré tous atp mp oui mais oui il
a raison il a raison mais moi j'ai un
ami pendant une heure
alors ça m'a joué entre eva longoria et
franchement c'est l'invité s'il est
arrêté en novembre regardez on va
accueillir celui dont je suis fan absolu
danseur que la seule question c'est moi
je me suis dit oh
oui parce que je regardais un petit peu
l'émission
avant de venir et je me suis dit ça va
être bien je vais en fait les
marseillais contre dubaï
a dit parce que on a un gros gros gros
dossiers on a beaucoup de choses à faire
on n'a pas un temps fou
mais
c'est quoi de bernard montiel de qui
voulait faire du cinéma j'aurais
vraiment pas vraiment si jamais ça vous
je suis moi j'en fais plus tôt
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai une suggestion capillaire vous
faut garder que tu ferais mieux
d'arrêter toile
une machine à vannes est sûre xavier et
c'est le seul invité qui anime à 10 avec
siri boxe a bien une qui partent toutes
les pages
et nigon qui
écrit sur leur avis